hi my name is Daniel Pham and welcome to
this week in Android development Monday
December ninth 2013 last week my ethnic
doppelganger made his debut on camera to
provide you with the week's updates our
first episode of uxd aired starring nas
MO and as guests of the week Isabel
Idris they introduce you all to you x
stay tuned for more episodes in this
series in the coming weeks lastly nettle
gave us a translated edition of app
indexing and Portuguese this week taran
wolf will host an episode of game on or
they'll talk about stuff that I can't
really talk to you about yet look for
this episode to air tomorrow that's it
for this week in Android development be
sure to subscribe to our channel so you
don't miss anything I'm Daniel Pham and
remember to take your time hurry up the
choice is yours don't be late